[Music]
grants welcome back I'm not gonna say
that you look like you flew a lot but
you look like yeah that was quite a trip
we had this long discussion about how
technology can change cities now you've
been around the world looking at that
very question are you feeling more
optimistic about that the cool thing is
I saw a lot of really incredible
companies cutting edge technology in
Portugal there's a company called venom
that is using Wi-Fi to create a giant
mesh network all around the city and
they're putting it on their buses so
that they can expand this network why is
this got a bigger impact on a city and
what else can they do with what they're
really doing is providing data to the
city about its infrastructure all the
data that's provided to the city will
help them see a lot of aspects of their
infrastructure that would otherwise be
totally hidden to them better data
better information generally better
planning where did you go next next it
was Tokyo to talk to a company called me
Thai and what they're doing is creating
an urban farm that is vertical and
indoors so they're addressing the food
issue do they describe what they're
doing as farming or is it something
different
it's absolutely farming it's tall and
it's high and there's rows and rows of
it that how does it taste it actually
tastes great wild cyndago Los Angeles
California and there's company they're
called daiquiri they have an augmented
reality system that they're using to
address issues with construction
building buildings of the future it's an
ideal interface to visualize many
different things there's gonna be all
kinds of applications for AR that are
starting to show up in the world and
Decker is one example where we're gonna
see a lot more technology also has a way
of creeping up and just becoming part of
our lives so maybe we're not quite there
yet but um it seems like we're headed in
the right direction I think I now
understand a lot of the core
technologies that we're gonna be seeing
with our cities in the future there's
more to learn I imagine
oh I think that Mouser and I have plenty
more technologies to learn about plenty
more places to go well when you do come
back and let's talk about it alright
thanks a lot
so that's it for me I think I'm gonna
get some much-needed rest I'd like to
thank Mouser electronics and some of
their leading suppliers like analog
devices Intel microchip technology and
molex for making this amazing journey
possible
[Music]